[موسيقى]
الاجرام الاسرائيلي في فلسطين غير مسبوق
في العالم الحديث منذ المحرقه الوحشيه
التي ارتكبها النازيون بحق اليهود يقول
حقوقيون لكن هل فكرتم يوما في ان تضعوا
انفس في موضع الاسرائيليين لتقولوا لنا
ماذا انتم فاعلون وهل ستستعمل ا ذاك القوه
المفرطه ام انكم
ستسالون اسرائيل ارتكبت المجازر وقتلت
السكان والاهالي منذ عام
1948 وحتى يومنا هذا في دير ياسين
والطنطورة وجنين بفلسطين وقان وصبر وشات
بلبنان ومصنع ابو زعبل وبحر البقره في مصر
وصولا الى مستشفى المعمدان ومجزره جباليا
والعدوان المفتوح على غزه لو كنتم محل
اسرائيل وقتلتم كل هؤلاء وما تبتم واحتلم
الارض وما زلتم واعتقلت الاحرار وبغيت
المن تكونوا خائفين من رده الفعل على
ظلمكم
ومستعدين لارتكاب اعنف المذابح هربا من
اليوم الموعود يسال مراقب ويضيف لماذا لا
تكون منطقيين اسرائيل وجدت لتقتل من يرفض
احتلالها فلا تقم الحجه عليها العالم معها
بل اقم الحجه على نفسك امام الله وامام
التاريخ الى
العناوين نبوءه زوال اسرائيل هل تتحقق بعد
اربع سنوات من
الان نتنياهو يتبنى فتوى دينيه تحض على
الاباده
الجماعيه تلبيب تتعهد بتحقيق نبوءه اشعياء
حول اسرائيل
الكبرى مستشار للبنتاجون يتحدث عن اشلاء
جنود امريكيين في غزه
ماذا طلب الناطق باسم القسام من حكام
الدول
العربيه هل تبادل حماس الاسرائيليين
الفرنسيين بجماجم
الجزائريين محمد رمضان قريبا على الشاشه
في دور ابو
[موسيقى]
عبيده مرحبا ان كنت ناسي يا نتنياهو ابو
عبيده حيفك كرك هكذا علق مصريون على حديث
الناطق باسم كتائب القسام عما يوصف بنبوه
اسرائيليه تعرف بلعنه العقد الثامن حيث لا
تعمر دولتهم في التاريخ اكثر من 80 عاما
لتبدا بالفسخ من
داخلها اربعه اعوام تفصلنا عن زوال
اسرائيل بحسب النبوءه التي يقر بها
العارفون من اليهود زمن انكسار الصهيوني
قد بدا ولعنه العقد الثامن ستحل عليهم
يقول الاسرائيليون واستنادا الى التورات
والتلمود ان اليهود اقاموا دولتين الاولى
هي مملكه النبيين داوود وسليمان التي لم
تصمد اكثر من 80 عاما اما الثانيه فهي
مملكه الحشمونائيم التي تاسست في العام
140 قبل الميلاد وايضا سقطت في عقدها
الثامن فزمن انكسار الصهيونيه قد
بدا ولعنه العقد الثامن ستحل عليهم ابو
عبيده لم يكن اول من اشار الى لعنه العقد
الثامن بل ان مؤسس حركه حماس الشيخ احمد
ياسين تنبا في العام
1999 بزوال اسرائيل في العام 2027 انا
اقول ان اسرائيل بائده ان شاء الله في
القرن القادم في الربع الاول منه
وبالتحديد انا بقول 2027 بتكون اسرائيل مش
موجوده ليس فقط الشيخ الشهيد احمد ياسين
بل ان بنيامين نتنياهو يعترف بكل هدوء
ووعي بلعنه الثمين اما ايهود براك فيكاد
يحزم حقائبه منذ الان لعنه استشهد بها
رئيس وزراء اسرائيل بنيامين نتنياهو ولعله
اول من تحدث عنها بوضوح وقال بكل صراحه
لشعبه انا الضامن الوحيد لكم لاستمراريه
اسرائيل وكسر هذه اللعنه وتحدث عنها
باسهاب اكثر رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
السابق ايهود بارك معتبرا ان التجربه
التاريخيه تشير الى ان الكيان سيندثر قبل
الذكرى الين لتاسيسه كان يكفي ان تعتقد
حرم رئيس وزراء الاحتلال ساره نتنياهو ان
بعلها بيبي لم يرد بشكل واضح اثناء مؤتمره
الصحفي على سؤال حول ما اذا كان قد تلقى
تحذيرا عسكريا بشان نوايا حماس ببدء الحرب
فطلبت منه التالي وفق تاكيد القناه
الثانيه ع
الاسرائيليه مع تصرفنا بسيناريو المحادثه
بنيامين افتح هاتفك الذكي ايها الغبي
واكتب الان تغريده اتهم بها رؤساء الاجهزه
العسكريه والامنيه الاسرائيليه بالتقصير
والتسبب بهزيمه اسرائيل امام ضربه السبت
الشهير لكتائب القس
بعد اوامر الزوجه ادرك نتنياهو انه في
المنطقه الخطره بين غضب ساره وما ادران ما
سارى وغضب قاده الجيش والمخابرات والشرطه
ففضل الرضوخ لعقيل الته وعدم اغضبها ونفذ
المطلوب
بحذافيره كتب التغريده التي سودت وجهه مع
كل عسكري وامني في اسرائيل اكثر ما هو
اسود فهل نحن امام حرب اسرائيليه
سياسيه داخليه وصل هذا السؤال الى الصحف
العبريه والعالميه فاضطر نتنياهو صاغرا
لان يعتذر من المستوى العسكري الاسرائيلي
الذي زادت شكوكه ببنيامين الذي لم يكسب
بدوره ثقه المراه القويه ساره والتي لا
يستبعد ان يكون لها اسهام فعلي على طريق
لعنه الثمانين وتفكك اسرائيل يعلقون كبار
قاده الجيش والمؤسسه الامنيه باسرائيل هم
المسؤولون عن فشل صد هجوم حماس في السابع
من اكتوبر هكذا برر نتنياهو ما حدث رافضا
الاعتراف بمسؤوليته المباشره قبل ان
يتراجع تحت ضغط سياسي وشعبي ويقدم اعتذارا
في سيناريو متخيل اخر بعد انتشار صوره
لنجل نتنياهو يا اير مستمتعا بوقته على
شواطئ ميامي في الولايات المتحده خاطب
رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي هرتس
بنيامين نتنياهو وقال له يا اير ابنك عم
يسبح ببحر ميامي وجيشنا غاطس بمستنقع غزه
فرد عليه نتنياهو وهل تصدق ان ياور ابني
عمللي بلوك على
التليفون
19 عندما عرضنا الحلقه السابقه ايمان هذا
الحاخام المستمد من كتابه المقدس بوجوب
تنفيذ حملات اباده جماعيه لا تاخذها
الرحمه بالاطفال والنساء والشيوخ بحسب
قوله كنا نظن انه حاله شاذه في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ليتبين للعالم هذا الاسبوع ان
نفس ايمانه يعتنقه ويلتزم به رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو الذي استشهد بنصوص مق
قدسه تدعو الى اباده اطفال ونساء
الاعداء
معخ رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو عندما اقتبس من العهد القديم وهو
بانه يجب
عليهم ان يقتلوا كل رجل وامراه وطفل رضيع
بقرا وغنما وحملا و حمارا هذا ما قاله في
مؤتمره الصحفي اليس ذلك نوع
من صوره واضحه لما يريد ان يفعله هل يريد
نتنياهو ان ينافس بنفير بن تفير بن شفير
على ساحه التطرف في اسرائيل هل اصبح
نتنياهو العلماني في دعايته السابقه
حاخاما معمما في حربه الجديده على اطفال
غزه
ونسائها رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي الجديد
الجمهوري مايك جونسون يلاقي تهوي نتنياهو
حربه على الفلسطينيين باعطائها بعدا
مسيحيا اضافيا حين يقول نحن
كمسيحيين يعلمنا الكتاب المقدس وجوب
الوقوف الى جانب
اسرائيل نتنياهو يفترض ان له قاء من العرب
ويحذرهم من ان نهايه اسرائيل تعني نهايتهم
فيقول ان لم ننتصر سياتي دوركم حسب زعمه
حلفائنا في المجتمع الغربي وشركا في
العالم العربي يفهمون اليوم اذا اسرائيل
لم
تنتصر سوف يكونوا هم الدور سياتي اليهم من
محور الشر هذا في نفس الوقت ودون خجل
نتنياهو يت وعدوا اهل المنطقه بانه ومن
معه سيحققون ما قال انها نبوءه اشعياء
التي ترسم حدودا توسعيه كبرى لاسرائيل
تبتلع ام الدنيا مصر وبلاد الرافدين
العراق وغيرهما من بلاد العرب والمسلمين
بحسب الاحاطه الثقافيه الدينيه للاعلام
المصري
نتنياهو الذي لبث ثياب الكهنوت واعلنها
حربا دينيه كما علق متابعون وصف بني
اسرائيل بانهم ابناء النور ويقاتلون ابناء
الظلام بهم بخ
و ولماذا يريد ان يجعلها حرب دينيه واحنا
عارفين ان هذه النبوءه بتتحدث على نبوءه
ان الاسرائيليين هتبقى حدود دولتهم من
النيل الى الفرات هل تعتبر تصريحات
نتنياهو تهديدا مباشرا لجمهوريه مصر
العربيه ووحده اراضيها وشعبها في اطار
دوله ذات سياده
مستقله هذا جانب من الفصل المصري مما قال
ياهو عنها انها نبوءه اشعياء تقول الايات
ها هو الرب قادم الى مصر يركب سحابه سريعه
فترتجف اوثان مصر في حضرته وتذوب قلوب
المصريين في داخلهم واثير مصريين على
مصريين فيتحول ويقوم الواحد على اخيه
وتنضب مياه النيل وتجف الاحواض وتيبس وكل
مزرعه على النيل تيبس وتتبدد وتكون ارض
يهوذا رعبا لمصر
في ذلك اليوم يمتد طريق من مصر الى اشور
ومن اشور الى مصر فيعبد المصريون
والاشوريون الرب معا في ذلك اليوم يكون
اسرائيل ثالث ثلاثه مع مصر واشور وبركه في
وسط الارض فيبارك الرب القدير قائلا مبارك
شعب مصر وصنعه يد اشور وميراث اسرائيل اين
افرازات اسرائيل والغرب الدهنيه والذهنيه
في مصر وغيرها
الذين يشغلون ساعاتهم المدفوعه سلفا
بانتقاد علماء الدين وما يسمونه الاسلام
السياسي هل راوا في فكر نتنياهو وما يمثل
من شريحه ناخب غالبه في اسرائيل اي دينيه
سياسيه يسال الداعيه الازهري الاستاذ عبد
الله رشدي والعجب العجاب ان انا م لقيتش
يعني الجماعه المثقفين اياهم اللي وجعوا
دماغنا سنين من 2011 تجديد الخطاب الديني
طب ليه ما حدش فيكم طلع النهارده تتكلم
وعمل فيلم زي ما انتم بتعملوا في كل مره
ليه ما طلعتو تتكلموا على موضوع تجديد
الخطاب الديني عند الراجل ده في المله
بتاعته بيقول كلام خطير جدا طب ليه ما
حضراتكم ما طلتوش تحللوا النصوص التي عنده
زي ما بتعملوا كده في نصوص الاسلام مصر
مذكوره في النبوءه دي انتم فكرتوا ان انتم
تطلعوا تتكلموا طب حد فيكم فكر يوجه نداء
لاي حاخام ولا اي رجل دين من هذه المله
يقول له اطلع لو سمحت فسر لنا البني ادم
اللي عندكم ده بيقول
ايه ونقول له ان زمن بيع الوهم للعالم حول
اكذوبه الجيش الذي لا يقهر والمركزه
الخارقه والاستخبارات المتفوقه كل هذا
انتهى زمنه بعون الله دور الناطق باسم
كتائب القسام ابو عبيده ان يقول مثل هذا
الكلام عن جيش الاحتلال لرفع المعنويات
الفلسطينيه والعربيه لكن ماذا عن مستشار
وزاره الدفاع امريكيه السابق دوجلاس
ماكغريغور انه يتحدث عن اشلاء مفقوده في
غزه لمقاتلي قوات نخبه امريكيه اثناء
محاولتهم اقتحام القطاع ويحذر المستشار
الامريكي حكومه بلاده في واشنطن من ان ذلك
لا يشكل انتصارا لاسرائيل بل يشكل خطرا
على
الامريكيين
isra
gaz free
hesa they shot to and took heaves i i
think
where وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي ايمار
بينر هل يكرس صوره المجتمع الحربي الكامل
للاسرائيليين
فينزع اي صفه للمدنيه عنه بدعوته الجميع
الى التسلح والاستعداد للقتل والقتال لكن
ماذا سيفعل المستوطنون اذا كانت قوات
النخبه الاسرائيليه لم تستطع الا قتل
الاطفال والعزل في البيوت جدعون ليفي صحفي
اسرائيلي يبدو اكثر فهما من اقرانه ينعي
قدره جيش الاحت
على خوض حرب بريه لان جنوده تخصصوا في
ملاحقه اطفال نابلس ونصب الحواجز في
الضفه
دمرت الروايه الاسرائيليه ببضع كلمات ليلى
موران نائبه في بريطانيا عائلتها لامها من
مسيحي قطاع غزه بفلسطين دمر منزلها
بالكامل وهي الان لاجئه في الكنيسه وتن في
ليلى ان تكون حركه حماس مقيده لتحركات
عائلتها palestin my dad british three
generations in the first week of the
following the atci that were committed
by hamas on october the 7th an idf bomb
hit their house and they went to their
local church christian palestinians and
they've been there ever since there are
100 people now in that church and we are
deeply deeply worried for their safety i
would a couple of things first of allan
i heard
g noer
people من اقوال رئيسه وزراء اسرائيل
الراحله مائير اننا لن نغفر للعرب انهم
اجرون على قل اطفالهم يعني نحن العرب
مجرمون لاننا ننجب الاطفال
لسكاكين وهم دائما
مظلومون بحسب تقرير لهيئه انقاذ الطفوله
فان عدد الاطفال الذين قتلتهم اسرائيل في
قطاع غزه خلال ثلاثه اسابيع تجاوز المعدل
السنوي لقتل الاطفال بمناطق الصراع دوليا
منذ اربع سنوات ويشكل الاطفال
40% من اجمال
الشهداء في غزه الالم والحاجه لا يعنيان
الخنوع والخضوع انا رافع راسي فوق انه كل
العالم الظالم اتامر علينا ومش اتامر بس
بالكلمه لا بعثوا سواريخ وبعثوا طيارات
وبعثوا حامل تناقل طائرات وبعثوا جند
وبعثوا كذا وبعثوا جيش وبعثوا استخبارات
هلقد غزه قويه انا افتخر ان من غزه افتخر
من هذا الب
ابو عبيده لا يريد اقلاق اي جهه عربيه
بحديث نفس عن تحريك
الجيوش ابو عبيده يوجه رساله للمسؤولين
العرب حول عجزهم عن ادخال الخبز للمدنيين
في غزه ولكن هل وصل بكم الضعف والعجز انكم
لا تستطيعون تحريك سيارات الاغاثه
والمساعدات الانسانيه الى جزء من ارضكم
العربيه الاسلاميه الخالصه رغما عن هذا
العدو المهزوم المازو فهذا ما لا نستطيع
فهمه وتفسيره لسكان مصر وغزه اصبح
بامكانكم الاستغناء عن محرك البحث جوجل
للحصول على المعلومات الطبيه والصحيه فقد
اصبح يقدمها مجانا وبنفسه وبدون انترنت
وزير الصحه المصري خالد عبد الغفار الذي
يحذر عن بعد من خطر انتشار الاوبئه في في
قطاع غزه لكنه لم يحدثنا عن اي حلول ماس
سكان غزه لا تتوقف عند القتل والدمار
والجوع هناك ازمه اخرى بدات ملامحها تلوح
في الافق وهي انتشار الامراض والاوبئه
اطراف كثيره حذرت من ذلك اخرهم وزير الصحه
المصري اذ توقع انتشار عدد من الاوبئه في
القطاع عندما نتحدث عن ازدواجيه المعايير
في الغرب فهذا لا يعني ان الشرق على جده
العد والانصاف سيرجي لافروف وزير خارجيه
روسيا يدين الارهاب بلا زغره في اشاره الى
عمليات المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي تستضيفها
موسكو من حين لاخر تم تنفيذ هجوم ارهابي
غير مقبول على الاطلاق ضد اسرائيل واعلنت
اسرائيل علنا دون ان تسترشد حرفيا
بالقانون الدولي ان ردها سيكون بلا رحمه
وانها ستدمر حماس لكن تدمير حماس مستحيل
دون تدمير غزه والده اسيرين مزدوجي
الجنسيه الفرنسيه والاسرائيليه تريد حلا
عاجلا من نتنياهو الذي يضحي بالاسرى بدل
ان يوقف الحرب ويفرغ المعتقلات هنا وهناك
اطالب باتفاق فوري مع حماس وبوقف اطلاق
النار
وبتباس اذا لم يقوموا بهذه المحادثات هذا
يعني ان الحكومه تضحي بطفلي وبالم اسير
الاسرائيليين يسال فرنسي من اصول جزائريه
لماذا لا تبادر الحكومه الفرنسيه الى عرض
مبادله الاسرى الفرنسيين الاسرائيليين
بجماجم
الجزائريين الذين قطع رؤوسهم جيش الاحتلال
الفرنسي الداعشي وفق التعبير الرائج
باعتراف الاعلام الفرنسي الرسمي اثناء
احتلاله الجزائر وتنفيذه حملات الاباده
المنظمه على حد تعبير وسؤال حفيد شهيد
جزائري كما اسلفنا نحن في مخازن متحف
الانسان بالعاصمه الفرنسيه باريس حيث تحفظ
حوالى 18 ال جمجمه بشريه هذه جماجم تم
العثور على اغلبها في بعثات التنقيب التي
تمت خلال القرن
ال من بين الاف هذه الجماجم 500 فقط تم
التعرف على هويات اصحابها من ضمنهم 36
قائدا من المقاومه الجزائريه قتلوا ثم
قطعت رؤوسهم من قبل قوات الاستعمار
الفرنسي في اواسط القرن ال ع ثم بعد ذلك
ياتيك رئيس فرنسا ايمانويل ماكرون ليطرح
فكره انشاء تحالف دولي لمقاتله حركه حماس
بدل انشاء تحالف دولي لاكرام ضحايا
المقابر الجماعيه الذين قتلهم دواعش فرنسا
في القرن الماضي يعلق ناشطون
فرنسا مستعده لان يقوم التحالف الدولي ضد
داعش بمقله حماس ايضا وانا اقترح على
شركائنا ان نبني تحالفا اقليميا ودوليا
لمحاربه الجماعات الارهابيه التي تهددنا
جميعا عندما يقتل فلاديمير بوتين المدنيين
في اوكرانيا بحسب واشنطن فهذا عمل وحشي
تذرف له دموع المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض
جون كيربي الذي يتكور بيعمل كورب التفاف
حين يقتل نتنياهو الاطفال والنساء في
فلسطين فهذه ضريبه متوقعه لاعمال العنف
يقول
رجل اعمال امريكي هندوسي يرشح نفسه لرئاسه
الولايات المتحده بلا زغره يقول امام
الائتلاف اليهودي الجمهوري ان متشوق لقطع
رؤوس قاده حركه المقاومه الاسلاميه في
فلسطين وتعليقها على الاوتاد فوصفه
حقوقيون بانه من دواعش الهندوس وفق
تعبيرهم هذا الهندسي رف الرخيص كما وصف هل
غاب عنه مشهد بنيامين نتنياهو وهو يحرج
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الهندوسي ريشي
سوناك في اسرائيل عندما رفض نتنياهو ضمه
وتقبيله بل مشى امامه واضعا يده في جيبه
في مشهد اقل ما يقال عنه انه
استكبارية ظر مس الهندوس لان ذلك مناقض
للطهاره الشخصيه والروحيه ودائما بحسب
تعبيرهم وائل الدحدوح الذي عض على جرحه
العميق اكراما لوطنه وشعبه ورسالته
الاعلاميه افلتت السنه اسرائيليه كلمات
تؤكد ان اسره الدحدوح وضعت على جدول اهداف
الاغتيال الاسرائيلي لكن وائل يواصل كشف
يوميات العدوان بدون اضافات فالدم اثقل من
التصرف والحق ابلغ من الصياغات الانشائيه
نحن لسنا طرفا في هذه الحرب ولكن ننقل ما
يجري على الارض في حالتنا يعني بعض
المراسلين
الاسرائيليين العارفين بالشان الاسرائيلي
تحدثوا انه احنا استهدفنا عائله مراسل
قناه
الجزه
بم
مس ما نقوم به من عمل متواصل الان وبعد
ساعات من مباراه افراد اسرتي للثرى هذا
اكبر رد على سؤالك انه احنا مستمرين لن
يؤثر على التغطيه اخيرا الفنان المصري
محمد رمضان قريبا في دور ابو عبيده هكذا
رد رمضان على الهجوم الاعلامي العبري عليه
بعد دعوته الجيوش العربيه الى انقاذ غزه
من عدوان اسرائيل الرساله دي للقناه
العاشره الاسرائيليه اسم شخصيتي في
المسلسل القادم ان شاء الله ابو عبيده
كثيرون علقوا على عرضنا فيديو محمد رمضان
الاسبوع الماضي بان هذا الممثل ليس الا
راكب
للموجه صراحه نحن ما عننا كشافات ولا
حساسات على النوايا لكن لا باس ليركب
الجميع موجه فلسطين ولنبتعد عن موجات
اسرائيل
لا عدل على هذه
الارض لنا الله وحسبنا هو الوكيل ختاما
كان هذا مندوب فلسطين في الامم المتحده
يذرف دموع العجز والكسل والجبن والبخل
والهرم والقسوه والغفله والعيله والذله
والمسكنه في ارض لا عدل فيها ويردد ما
ردده المستضعفون من قبله ملنا غيرك يا
الله فهل يتحول شعار ملنا غيرك يا الله
الى نشيد للامه العربيه والاسلاميه
الراهنه حتى يخرج منها من يعيد القدس الى
اهلها من مسلمين ومسيحيين كما اعادها عمر
وصلاح الدين يسال مهجر عن وطنه الى
اللقاء يا الله مالنا غيرك يا الله يا
الله مالنا غيرك يا يا الله يا الله من لا
غيرك يا الله يا الله منلا غيرك يا الله
يا الله منلا غيرك يا الله
صامدون هنا
صامدون هنا قرب هذا الدمار العظيم وفي
يدنا يلمع الرعب في يدنا في القلب غصن
الوفاء
[موسيقى]
النضير